thank you uh so i'd like to thank the
organizers for inviting me for this to
this very interesting conference um
and
i actually changed my title if you if
you noticed so the reason i changed my
title is i was going back and forth
between talking about what was the
original title which is about reverse
hyper connectivity and talking about the
second topic the second topic is is a
bunch of observations
which are nice and i wish that somebody
has told me these observations five or
six years ago so i'm going to share this
observation with you and what's nice
about these observations is that they
were actually
observed here at the institute like in
the last couple of weeks so there are
going to be two parts in the first part
i'm going to talk a little bit about
reverse hyper contactivity i apologize
to those of you who've seen a version of
this at cambridge maybe a couple a year
or two ago and then in the second part
i'm going to talk about something that's
really new that's from the last recorder
and uh
one of the reasons i changed the title
is that with the in at in the edge of
the internet
there is a rumor that actually
christopher bowell may be watching this
talk as we're speaking and they will
send emails to jeff if you have any
questions or comments
okay
so the first part of the talk i'm going
to talk about the joint work with with
both arnab and and
sister for both sitting here and it's
going to be about reverse hyper
contactivity
and again i'm going to go to go even
maybe a little faster than i'm usually
going because
we've seen this this this this kind of
stuff
quite a bit during the workshop but i'm
going to talk about
noise noise stability or no sensitivity
in the discrete hypercube the fact that
there's a half here means that i'm
looking at the uniform measure on the
hypercube and tt is the noise markov
operator where the noise what in the
previous
on then called rho rho square now it's
going to be e to the minus t
so given x i'm going to pick a y how am
i going to pick a y for each coordinate
independently with probability e to the
minus t is going to stay the same and
with the other pull with the remaining
probability i'm going to derandomize it
so that's the noise that we're going to
look at so that's one definition an
equivalent second definition is the
functional definition we act from we act
on functions what do we do to a function
well it's probability e to the minus t
if we look at the function on the two
point space this probability e to the
minus t we stay at the function and
otherwise we add average the function so
this is the operator on the two point
space and then we look at
minus one one today and we are looking
at the ends and wise tensor of this
operator
and
i'm going to do the usual crime of
choosing a subset of the names of the
names that should be here so
this is a random subset of the names
that should be but with some weights
corresponding to
something okay
again
oh sorry
okay
right so there's some there's some
semi-group noises acting here i
apologize for that and that's and that's
the that's the hyper-contractive
inequality which we which we all know so
you look at tt at f at the higher known
p it's less than f at the smaller norm q
as long as the the semi group one for
long long enough and we know the tide
constant for this so t has to be at
least one half
log p minus one over q minus one
okay so i'm going to go quickly but
please interrupt me if something looks
unfamiliar or we want it to go slower
so okay the the experts in this in in
the top in the next
next topic i want to comment about
briefly because this is going to be
related to what i'm actually going to
talk about is what happens if we look at
other discrete spaces
so instead of looking at the space zero
one to then it's the uniform measure you
can imagine you want to look at some
other probability distribution so for
instance you can look at this space zero
one to the
zero one with alpha to the n which means
that alpha is taken with probability one
in each coordinate independently
you can ask the same question what can
we say about hyper hyper conductivity
or you can ask about some general
products rate omega to them may be
discrete maybe not discrete the question
is again what can you say about hyper
contractivity in this setup
okay so again the semi group is going to
be the same semi group that we we've
been talking about before so again two
interpretation one interpretation is
that if you think about the random work
the random walk
each coordinate it keeps the same as
possible e to the minus t and otherwise
it picks it according to the stationary
distribution on the one-dimensional
space that we're looking at and the
functional version is that in one
dimension what we're doing when we act
on functions
we take the average probability 1 minus
e to the minus t and otherwise we take
this probability to the minus t we take
the function itself
okay
so again
this the points i'm putting right now
is since the exports are on the room i'm
not going to to go into too much detail
but a lot is known and this result by by
sister felix carricks and and power wolf
and uh
there are similar results in this in the
setup of logs so we'll have logs of live
inequalities which we know and i don't
want to go over all of these
inequalities but i'll just let me just
highlight maybe i should have
highlighted in the slides
what are the key the key what what is
the key points i want you to to to look
at so somehow in this hyper hyper
contractive inequality which look
exactly the same way that we've we've
seen before so there's a higher norm
over here there's a there's a lower norm
over here
what what we see is that there's some
dependence on the norm but there's also
some dependence on the space so there's
this quantity log of one over alpha
where alpha
in the case of zero one is the
probability of the smallest atom among
zero one and alpha in the case of a
general discrete probability space is
the probability of the smallest atom in
the space
so what does it mean it means that
suppose we all like to apply
hypercontractive inequalities and we are
used to doing it in the discrete cube
zero one to then with the uniform
measure if we want to apply it in a
different product structure we can do it
but we lose something what do we lose
what we lose in this scaling which we
talk
talks about the time what we lose is we
lose a factor you know the time has to
be bigger by a factor which is log of
one over the smallest probability of any
atom in the space right so which is
something that we some of us are well
aware of because if you remember if we
looked at examples say well the
probability measure was gave one
probability one over n and zero it gets
probability one minus one over n and we
know that you know something like kkl
doesn't hold in this setup why doesn't
it hold in the setup it doesn't hold
because the hyper-contractive
inequalities as we know them do not hold
what do we lose we lose log of one over
alpha when alpha is n which means that
we look
a factor of log n so it's exactly the
log n that we gain we lost and therefore
kkl doesn't tell you anything in this
setup where the space is very is very
vast and this is necessary so these
inequalities are sharp and you know
there's nothing you can do about it
these are the titles
any questions so far
okay good
so
now we're going to talk about
reverse bounce so this is this is a
in a paper of crystal ball from 82 this
notion of reverse hyper contactivity was
was introduced earlier in the gaussian
context in the paper of berlin and
svante janssen also for that was
published in 82 and the setup is the
following the statement is the following
statement so again we are looking at the
uniform measure on the discrete cube
now we are looking
now we are looking at a positive
function
and the inequalities are going to be
somewhat reversed so everything is going
to be reversed and
it will only make sense if the functions
are positive so the function here takes
positive or non-negative value and the
statement is the following if you look
at the q's norm of t t of f it's greater
than the p's norm of f
okay
so
averaging
increases the norm
for norm
q that less than one p
and actually both of the norms are not
norms because they don't satisfy the
triangular inequality they're semi norms
because p and q are both less than one
and they can actually be negative
this is this is the reverse inequality
and everything about it looks reverse
right this inequality goes in the other
direction the norms are actually not
norms and you know everything looks very
very stretchy about this inequality and
and it's it's the the wild paper is a
wonderful paper and in fact this fact
appears in about
the statement and the proof take about
10 lines in the paper okay you know it's
mostly about hyper conductivity and then
crystal observes they said well in fact
you know if you do the opposite you know
you see that all the opposites are
preserved and you know you repeat the
same proof then you have to check the
following inequality and you check it
and it's fine
okay so that's everything that you see
in the table it takes a little bit of
decision to do but but crystal ball did
it very very nicely in the paper maybe
i'll comment a little bit how about how
he proved it okay so let me say a little
a little bit more about about about the
statement so that's the statement that
we're going to talk about
the first question i'm going to ask for
those of you who haven't seen it before
does this statement make any sense
and in order to talk about what senses
make so let me tell you a little bit
about uh norms that or seminoles for or
this these norms for p less than one
so the first thing that you have to note
is that even without hyper conductivity
if you look at a positive quantity or
positive function averaging actually
increases speeds norm for p less than
one
okay so
indeed even before n is anything
sophisticated just if you take a mark of
operator you average a non-negative
function the p's norm is going to
increase
similarly if you look at something if
you want to apply something like kochi
schwarz or helder inequality you can do
it but it goes in the opposite direction
so if you look at a two nodes p and p
prime that are dual the sum of the
received vocals is this one but the
norms are less than one and in f and g
again everything has to be positive one
and no negative if f and g are both
non-negative functions then the expected
value of f times g we are used to the
fact that it's less or equal than
something but it's going to be greater
or equal than something so it's going to
be greater or equal than the p nodes of
f and the the conjugate norm of gnp
one of them is going to be negative yeah
but we're okay with negative no and once
you
allow yourself the flexibility of the
mind to talk about norms less than one
negative notes are not such a big deal
okay so it's like so the nose can be yes
the nouns can be negative too
okay and and if you think about these
two
basic results which were definitely
known to hardly or probably even before
if you think about these two results
then maybe it's not so surprising that
those things go in the other direction
right so you expect averaging to
increase but not just in the p norm
maybe you can even gain more by by
getting something in the in the smaller
norm in the q number that you get in the
q knob that that the average according
to the semi group of f is greater than
the norm or according to the p naught as
long as the same good point for long
enough okay so this was just to explain
why this inequality might make sense
okay so
i'm going to explain
briefly
why is this inequality
too i started at 10 20 right
okay yes okay so i'm going to explain
briefly yz2 so i'm going to explain in a
similar way to borel i'm going to show
you very quickly a short proof and try
to convince you that it's actually work
but i won't actually go over the proof
and then i'm going to tell you what is
it good for so this is all
very you know all the news and then i'm
going to talk about what is it true for
other spaces
okay so here is
an exp you know usually you do the
opposite right usually when you present
a part of a paper
the
information on your slides is less
is less than what's in the paper what
i'm going to do now i'm actually going
to present something that's small in
what's bored
for a boreless result right so the
reversal so it's going in a reverse
direction and we're actually going to
expand i'm going to devote two slides to
something that borel did in like 10
lines but let me still do that because i
think it could be it can be useful so
here's borah's argument
so bored says okay how do you prove
things like that he said at the time we
reported he said we already know that in
quality is like distensorized and what
do we need to tensorize in in order to
tensorize in qualities like the hyperion
hypercontracting in qualities we need
mean call screen quality and in p less
than one we have reverse minkowski since
the inequality goes in the other
direction since reverse minkowski was
it's enough to prove it for the case of
one dimension so he says it's in one
line i did it in two okay
then he says you know actually you don't
have to consider all of the range of the
parameters because various arguments
about continuity and more important
duality
shows you that it's enough to show it
for specific values of p and q because
the other ones are dual of this
parameter so it's enough to show it for
parameters p and q as before but
positive right the negative ones even so
i said that we are flexible enough to
accommodate actually working with them
is a pain so you know duality lets you
actually work just with p and q that are
strictly positive
and then what's the core of the proof
that i'm going to show you in in in in
the next slide so the call of the proof
we are going to use something that's you
know not necessarily completely standard
in hyper contractivity we are just
talking about positive functions so up
to scaling we can we can write our
positive functions in the form one plus
a times x where a is some number between
minus one one again we are on the two
point space right so every function is a
linear function it's a positively enough
function so up to multiplying by a
constant
the function that we're looking at is
just one parameter it's one plus a x
where is between minus one and one okay
so now all you know after applying sort
of this general machinery translated to
the reverse setup all we have to do is
to prove that this inequality for these
specific functions for this specific
familiar function
so this is what we need to do
and then you do what you have to do and
you know again
i don't think that borel actually writes
these formulas in this paper i think he
only writes this he says you have to
check this and this is true
okay so this is what he said
what do you do what do you do you say
okay i'm going to expand
the piece node to the p and i'm going to
what i should compare it to is the the
norm of the cues norm to the p but let
me first write the q's node to the q so
i write it in the analytical sum that i
can write it so this is the piece known
to the p this is the q's known to the q
and then what i'm interested actually is
the piece name of this quantity not the
excuse now so i have to take the power p
over q now p is greater than q so i have
convexity so i can just lower bound what
i'm after just by the by the first order
correction so i get this expression then
all i have to do is i have to compare
this expression to this expression
and i'm just going to do it term by
terms i have to com to show that this
expression is always going to equal this
expression then you simplify and you get
that you have to show this inequality
and then you know you do the calculus
and you see that this inequality always
holds and this is how you prove deliver
cycle contact
very elementary and it's really
you can give it to
first-year calculus students and you
know you will you will be able second
of the classical connectivity right so a
proof like that also works for that for
the hyper contract you can also prove
that contractive equality in a similar
way and i think actually that's one of
the things that bobel talks about in
about in the same paper
okay so you can you know
things are reversed the expansions are
different and so on and so forth but you
can prove the usual hyper-contracting
equality the same
good so yes i compared with the argument
in bonami's paper which was ten years
earlier she also proves the two points
yeah that's the difference
so this is this is different inequality
and you know as we will see this this
inequality okay so this is related to
the sort of the the general direction
which i want to go for in the next 10
minutes is to ask you know both the
question that michelle was asking
questions that one was asking the same
question you know are you doing anything
different or is it actually the same
right so that's when i read this paper
that's the question that i was asking is
it really different than the usual hyper
contractivity that we know is this
reverse really different so all the
arguments i presented so far and the
answer that i you know my answer to
michelle indicates that it's in in fact
the same thing so let's keep different
in the sense of what it can be applied
to or different no this is very
different right so this is a
philosophical question let's keep it in
our head for the next five minutes i'll
give you some applications and then
we'll start answering this question okay
so that's that's what i want to do it's
a good question but that's that's what
i'm going to talk about
okay so let me let me just give you a
couple of applications so this is this
is where i i got to learn about boiler
results this is a joint work with again
at least
two of the people are in the audience uh
so
john paper with cyanodonald reggae
jeff staff and bernie subacco will we
use this inequality and we use it in the
setup that i think might be interesting
to people who are interested in
probability in general
so we looked exactly at the setup of
points discrete cube that are all
correlated so rho is going to be e to
the minus t
the expected value of x i y is e to the
minus t
and for the the application that we had
in mind we needed statements of the
following form we needed to say that if
a and b are two subsets of the discrete
cube that are not too small so let's say
each of them is of measure at least
epsilon then the probability that x is
in a and y is in b is not too small
either
okay
and in fact
you rediscovered this uh right so among
other things we rediscovered it even
though our proof wasn't
i mean i think the there were there was
an evolution of the proof which ended by
the fact that we realized that braille
proof is the nicest
okay but you know it's like so yeah
okay so it's proof we realized how how
nice is the proof you know we were a
little disappointed that it was written
in so few lines right at some point but
you know if the proof is telling us okay
so what do we get in the setup so we get
in the setup that you know if you have
if for any two sets that are not too
small the probability that x is in a and
y isn't b is going to be at least
epsilon well it's at least the product
of the distribution the probability this
this is what you would want epsilon
square but you lose a little bit whether
you lose you lose a factor of one minus
e to the minus t right but at least if
the sets are are are
relatively big and the time t or the
correlation rho are
not the correlation is not too close to
one you get that the probability of this
intersection events of correlated x and
y is is pretty large
yes so essentially this boundary is
tight for opposing hummingbirds
second in the exponential
the constant in exponent is not right
right uh i think the cons actually i
think the collection is actually of
second order but uh
okay i don't remember it's been you know
that is younger than me remembers better
or something
it's
so of course if you get t goes to
infinity you know you expect it to
recover the product and you can cover
the product but the question you hear is
about the fixed right very good okay let
me just mention that the proof of this
inequality from this result is is
very very short
you you take moral results you apply
reverse holder inequality so if the
soldering quality gives you this
inequality again the inner product of g
with tt of f is at least f no p genome q
and now it holds for a symmetric
condition in p and q so the condition is
t has to be greater than essentially
minus one half log one minus q one minus
p and the point about this inequality is
that if you think about u and p
how how does this prob probability x
belong to a y belong to b
how this depends on t at all so t the t
depends on t is here x and y are uh
yeah x and y are raw correlated we're
always e to the minus t
so x is equal to y is probability 1 plus
e to the minus t over 2
x i equal to y i okay so when t goes to
infinity x and y are becoming
independent and then you get the trivial
bound epsilon square which is the the
comment of the low end that you know you
get epsilon square and you know the the
closer t is to zero the higher the power
of epsilon is so the more correlated x
and y are the higher the power you get
but still you get some sum results
okay statement about if the minus
expansion right
right so it's some statement about
expansion and one of the things
yeah it's clear that i'm going to run
out of time but one of the things i want
to do
maybe i'll do a few slides i'll talk
about comparison of this of saying it's
the expander mixing level okay so how
does this comparison expand the mixing
level so let me get to that so let me
just say the proof of this is pretty
pretty straightforward the main thing
that you have to notice is what the
height of conductivity gives you it lets
you choose boston and q and p to be
positive
once the norms are positive you get a
result that lets you actually talk about
probabilities of the set if it's
negative you don't you don't really get
okay let me skip this that was the
original application why we cared about
this problem in that paper but let me
skip it
and and again this is something that i
was planning to skip but you know one of
my favorite area of applications of this
result is is in what's called
quantitative social choice this is an
area that was essentially created by gil
and
in most of the results in this area
somehow when you want to prove this
strong result without neutrality you
have to use reverse cycle connectivity
and these are the results that are
highlighted by that that's that's the
result you actually need so that's
that's a very nice uh area of
applications of this results
okay so let me go back to the
philosophical question this was to
convince you that it's useful for
something it's a probabilistic tool
that's kind of cool uh useful for
something so let me go back to one
question and to michelle comment even
though michelle at least knows the
answer alright so you look at these two
inequalities
so again for bonamir for the swap i
should do slope again so you look at
these two inequalities and you know you
look at the proofs and what is the
conclusion the conclusion that i drew
for
number of years is that hyper
contractivity and reverse cycle
conductivity have to be exactly the same
thing
you know the inequalities are of course
different but maybe there's some duality
and once you prove one you prove the
other and you know i was just looking
for duality proof that says you know
once you prove hyper contractivity you
get invested in connectivity and vice
versa in particular one thing that they
didn't want to do is they didn't want to
recover the result of pagoda and shisht
for other probability spaces i said well
you know we know the results there
there's going to be some duality i'm
just going to smart and find this
duality and then i'm going to recover
all of the results okay so that was my
plan for various years and the surprise
and i think for both of the results of
the world that i'm going to talk about
one of the nice things that the results
are nice but there's also a surprise
the surprise is that this is false
so it turns out that for event cycle
conductivity
the inequality actually doesn't depend
at all on the underlying space
so you get a uniform reverse
hyper-contractive inequality no matter
what probability space you're looking at
so here's the result that we got with
with schistofen
so you look at any
any any product specs or omega to the n
any positive function
then you have a reverse hypercontractive
inequality of the form that we want with
no log one over alpha here there's no
dependence on the smallest atom on the
space this just holds completely
uniformly
okay so this is indicate i mean so this
was counterintuitive and the first
indication of that was i think ana was
doing some simulation we were trying to
actually find the constant and the
constant didn't go to you know
it didn't have any dependency on alpha
and this was of course an indication
that we have bags in the program and so
until you know we start suddenly realize
there's something different going on
here okay so if that cycle connectivity
is really different than hyper
contractivity in this in the sense that
it doesn't depend on the other line
expression let me try to explain
if f is a constant function then there
is equality right right so for all of
this all of this inequality whenever you
have a cons in this case constant
positive function the two sides are just
going to be this constant right so
that's just even this non-norms satisfy
this property right
okay so the result is clear
okay so uh okay so i already said that
so i'll try to tell you a little bit
about why is why this is true but let me
tell you
let me relate it more general to things
that that we know so
this doesn't just hold for product
spaces it holds for general mark of
summing groups
and and for instance we know the
following two results whenever you have
a log symbol of
inequality with constant c
or a one log sub-level constant which is
also called modify log so we'll have
constant with constant c then you have
reverse reverse cycle conductivity in
the sense that if the time is greater
than log one minus p over one minus p
with this constant over four then you
have the reverse inequality for every
positive function so this is the diff
this is
okay this result actually implies the
previous result i told you because it
turns out that the one log symbol of
inequality or the modified log sum of
inequality holds for every simple
probability space for every simple
operator so this result implies the
previous result but it somehow output
puts it in context and it shows that
the reverse hyper-contactive
inequalities or are
weaker than the standard log sub 11
qualities and they are also weaker than
the weaker inequalities that are called
modified or one log sub 11 quality
okay so that's that's that's another
part of the picture
and here's again the application so now
you have applications like that whenever
you you have one log sub level two logs
of eleven equalities you have exactly
the same kind of applications that we
had before
there's a missing two factor compared to
boral results which correspond to having
having this factor to here that we lose
but this now holds for general
probability spaces
and just for comparison say
uh let's compare it to what's called the
expander mixing element which is another
way of saying that you know if you have
two sets
you know the probability that x is in a
and y is in b is loud so this is one
bound for two sets of size epsilon you
get this bound and here's another bound
that's the expander next element tells
you the probability that x is in a and y
isn't b is at least the product minus an
arrow term or it's equal to the product
up to the electron what is the arrow
term the l term is square root of the
product of the probabilities of the set
times e to the minus t times the
spectral quantity so this is the what's
what you get in the
prank array inequality
okay
so
when you look at these two
inequalities which one is better
it depends very good that's a good
answer i wanted you not to answer at all
because it's not clear which one it
is in much greater generality for graphs
and
so what i'm talking about also holds
whenever you have i mean so okay so
let's
no so let's do let's do let's do it
let's do this let's compare the setups
again so the setups are completely
general but in one one case i'm going to
measure things according to the spectral
gap in other case i'm going to measure
it either according to the log server f
constant or according to the modified
log sub lift constant right so we know
that these are worse than the spectral
gap but i can do it in any setup that we
want right i can talk about a markov
chain or we can talk about some graphs i
can do it in any step that i want and i
can compare these two inequalities this
inequality is respect is the spectral
inequality and this inequality is the
inequality that you get from from this
locks overlap constant so the difference
between them sometimes this is better
this the bottom one is better than top
one sometimes the top one is better than
that the the lower one what is the
relationship so essentially what is
going on is that if the set a and b are
small
where smalling is compared to what we
the spectral information that we have on
the gap then this this low term is going
to be much bigger than papb and you're
not going to get anything however and
then this inequality gives you something
that even works if the sets are tiny
even if they're very very small you get
that this quantity is positive and you
know and you get a quantitative bond
however if the sets are large in the
sense that the square root times the e
to the minus t over d
is much smaller with the product of the
measure of the sets this typically is
going to be a much tighter the tighter
result about the probability of x in a
and y and b okay the locks overlap is
enough to imply this right so that's one
of the things that i quickly said in the
previous slide log sub levels enough to
imply it but in fact even a weaker
property which is called modify log
sobolev is enough to imply this
so logs of wave is the sense in some
sense equivalent to import conductivity
no right so log server is equivalent to
our connectivity but one of the messages
of this talk is that
reverse hyper contactive is implied by
something weaker so it's implied by log
server implied by something weaker
that's called a modified log sub level
quite in particular i get the example of
just a space of two points where you
have a big measure on one point and a
small measure on another point here the
logs overlap constant is deteriorating
as the space is becoming more and more
unbalanced while the modified locks are
whatever the reverse hyper contactivity
remain the same or you know this there's
an uniform doorbell okay so that's
exactly exactly what i'm trying to
configure
goods other
questions uh so i just have one comment
the thing is that in the
in the uh the expanded mixing level they
usually have an expander and an
adjacency matrix and you're comparing
you're proving a lower bound for this
in the above case you're actually
changing the chain and you're looking at
the
uh continuous chain right so so you need
to if you realize
the translation is done here this is the
translation of the expander mixing limit
to the continuous time markov chain
so the comparison is the cell comparison
right so it's like um this is the
continuous time markov chain and and
this is the continuous time markov chain
and the expander mixing dilemma doesn't
really care if you're in continuous time
or in discrete time the proof is the
same proof the statement that is you
know very closely related so in order to
make the comparison since this talk is
in continuous time i made a comparison
in continuous time but that's a good
point right so usually when people think
about the expander mixing lemma they're
used to you know you read about it in
this setup so you know but it's the same
actually didn't read it
right but it's the same it's the same in
continuity that's a that's a very good
comment very good
yes so a few minutes ago you were saying
that you were hoping at one point in
real life that the hyper contradictivity
and reverse cycle contractility would
turn out to be equivalent right from
what you said up to now is it still
feasible that there's an easy way to
deduce the reverse from from the
non-river right so this is okay so if i
okay so just so this is what the next
you know
okay maybe i'll i'll make a vote at some
point you know so the next slides are
supposed to tell you why can you deduce
one from the other and what is the
relationship between the usual and
hyper-contracted equality or the usual
log surveillance into the equality that
we're talking about right now that's
what i wanted to do okay so this slides
the escape it talks about situation
where you look at markov chains this is
just for your valve global dynamics in
high temperatures for other people you
talk about couch shuffling so this
inequality holds in this setup which
means again if you have one big set
you're running some markov chain
instructionality you ask what's the
probability that at some time in some
big but of measure epsilon set in some
other time i mean some other measure
options say you get uniform bounds that
just depend on the log several of the
modified logs of life constants right so
this really holds in the more general
set of the the setup of product chain
right so these are two examples that are
mentioned in our paper and in fact exist
also came up with a very beautiful
queuing example with elsmitcheski
okay so
in fact the main thing that we're
proving in this and this this is this is
uh this answers to some extent the
question that they would ask is is
asking what is going on here so
so if you want to talk about
to think about it at a high level one
way to think about it at a high level is
the following way
we already know
and you know we have to do a little bit
of work because i don't think no
anybody thought about it too seriously
in the context of reverse cycle
connectivity but we already know that
logs overlapping equality and and and uh
hypercon contract or in our case the
best reverse cycle contract inequalities
are the same
so this kind of analogy or or the fact
that you can take
take the
derivative of the semi group and relate
it to
holes in the general more general setup
that we're talking about and the main
the main thing that we actually prove in
our paper is a proof that this
inequality is a monotone right so
there's going to be log support of
inequalities for every known p and what
we're proving is that this is monotone
in the interval between 0 and 2. so if
you have log sub 11 quality for p and
you have log stability in quality for q
then if p is greater than q then the p1
implies the q1
so this is one of the reason why if
their cycle conductivity is easier than
hyperconvective it could be hyper
conductivity hyper conductivity is too
long so believe in quality and what
we're showing is that uh what we will
show is that for instance that
log one support inequality implies
reverse hyper contractility
so that's the main idea of the proof
so
uh
okay let me i always like to have a vote
in the in the talk right so i have two i
there are two options i can tell you a
little bit about how improved stuff
all i can tell you about plurality is
stabilist and the standard why
i will prove this stuff
prior to your status in the standard y
okay it's about equal so i can decide
very useful okay i will tell you how we
put this stuff
i'll just okay maybe i'll just make two
points so one point is that you have to
come up with the right definition of of
of p log solving equality and there is
the definition is standard in the
literature is entropy less than a
constant times the directional form of f
to the p minus one f
the main
since yeah this does something really
nice if you choose the right
normalization and the right
normalization is that you multiply the
constants there's an absolute constant
and then you take some
expression that depends on the norm this
expression is p squared over four p
minus one
and only if you take this
parametrization you get this
monotonicity that i talked about
okay so you have to take the right
definition and in the right definition
the constant in the
the the the logs of eleven equality
relating the entropy to the divisional
form has to be half needs to be some
function of the known p that you're
looking at so maybe it's worth saying
it's a product of p and the dual of p
right so so right so one of the one of
the things that you'll see here is that
this definition is is you know one of
the reasons
how you can derive it is you can see
that this definition is the property
that you satisfied p logs over them if
and only if you satisfy the the dual one
which is also a very aesthetic form and
also a reason why it's enough to look at
the interval zero to two you don't care
about the negatives the negatives are
just the duals of zero to one you don't
care about nodes greater than to the
other drawers between one and two and
this shows you that this maybe is the
right parametrization and then
and then you what you have to prove is
you have to prove a statement like that
so this is this is a statement stronger
than what's called the structurapolis
estimate so you have to prove something
about the the the
dirichlet energy
but when you look at p and q norms we
have to prove that if p is greater than
q then
for any number between 0 and 2 you have
to prove that this dirichlet form is
less than that divisional form and this
is of course not quadratic because there
are all these powers but the dirichlet
forms act in a quadratic way so this
reduces to actually proving a statement
about every two numbers a and b so you
have to prove that forever in two
numbers a and b you have this beautiful
inequality and then you prove it and
then you get this inequality and then
you plug it into the usual machinery and
the usual machinery will tell you this
this this this
point
these are the two this is the basic two
points in quality that you have to pull
all right this is just an overview of
what's going on in the setup so let me
tell you a little bit about about the
other
thing that i want to talk about so this
was the whole result
i want to talk about another bonus all
right so half spaces minimize the
gaussian surface area black theorem says
that
if you have two
correlated random variables then
if you look at any two functions f1 and
f2
the correlation between f1 and n and f2
of m is less or equal than the
correlation between the corresponding
half spaces so this will do functions f1
and f2 this is two function h1 and h2
the expected value of h this is a vector
this dex the same as the expected value
of f so f1 is the same expected value
for h1 f2 is the same expected value of
h2 and that's the more result that one
was mentioning in the previous talk when
we talk about two sets okay so that's
both this one
and it implies majority status which i
want i won't formulate now for a number
of years i'm obsessed with the following
question what happens if you divide the
space into three parts okay so two parts
we all understand very well but what
happens if you put
a partition displaced into slippers and
uh the only result that that we know
which sort of gave us a
hope that that something can be done for
sleepers
is what's called the double bubble
theory in gaussian space so this is from
about 10 years ago
there are many otters on the paper
that's why i didn't put it next to the
to you know so colonelico and how
there's assume adams also you notice
it's not alphabetically it's clear that
something interesting was happening in
this paper and so on and so forth so all
of these people are authors on this
matter that show that the double bubble
is optimal in gaussian space except in
that case it's called the standard y so
what is the standard y
standard why is the partition of rn into
three parts using three hyperplanes or
half hypoplanes all meeting at 120
degrees okay so let me just go i should
have done it before the talk
so this is the standard y where the
center is will determine the measure of
the three sets
and what did this guy prove
they addressed the isothermatic problem
so you want to find a partition like
that which minimizes the surface area
and they said the standard y minimizes
the surface area well as long as all of
the pieces are essentially of the same
measure so it shouldn't be the
difference between any pieces in measure
is more than zero point zero four
but what is this the question again what
is e1
okay so this is how i'm sorry this is
how i define partitions so it's easier
to do it in vector notation so i'm going
to have three parts of rn one of them is
going to map to the unit vector a1 one
of them is going to be mapped to the
unit vector a2 and one of them is going
to be mapped to the unit vector e3 what
i'm going to do is i'm going to measure
the gaussian surface area which i'm
denoting by gamma plus so gamma plus
this is the surface area of this
partition and i'm saying that this
surface area is bigger than the surface
area of the standard y where y is one of
these wise but this y can be shifted in
various ways and i choose the y that
satisfies that the measure of each part
is the same as the measure of the
corresponding partition
the surface area is the area of the
boundary the area of the boundary
of the boundary between the three parts
okay so in this case it's going to be
this
this co
one dimension code dimension one a yeah
this code dimension one area and this
good dimension i wanna the sum of these
three areas that's what it's going to be
okay so this is related to the
resolution of the double bubble theory
which was a very big big deal and in
fact they use a lot of the technology
that's been that's being used they
couldn't quite prove that the standard
white
which in other words you would call it
plurality minimizes the surface area but
it does minimize the surface area if the
parts differ by its most focused
okay so that's what they put that's all
we know
and of course you know given this there
are various natural questions
first of all just for the gaussian
another parametric problem what is what
happens if the partition is are not
almost balanced
is the similar statement to formula
stability
and you know is what we call plurality
established is it true for for discrete
probability spaces okay so this is a
question that i'm
asking myself for a lot of time and in
the last two weeks we realized something
so we realized that the kind of
statement that we have in the case of
borel cannot hold
so this is again joint joint discussion
with stephen and joe we realized that
this kind of claims that we can make in
the case of uh in the case of the
theorem of bowel do not hold in the
setup that we're talking about now so
now i'm not going to talk about one
partition i'm going to talk about two
partitions so i'm going to consider a
pair of partitions the parallel
partition is going to be given by f1 and
f2 and one partition i want to be
partitioned to slip parts each of
measure one cell one third one so one
cell
and the other partition i want to be
partitioning to two parts are going to
be of size one half and one part is
going to be of size zero
okay so we're trying to do something
like a bore lizard what did we do in
budarism we said okay i'm going to take
two partition of the space to two parts
in one partition the measure may be 50
50. in the other position maybe the
measures are going to be 75 percent and
25 percent what are the best partition
and barack said well the best partition
is to take
a hyper plane here and a parallel hyper
plane here one measure is going to be
one half of the space the other measure
is going to be three quarter of the
space and this is the optimal position
now we're asking a similar question in
partitioning three parts so if we
believe something like borel result
would be true in the y with conjecture
that you know the partition here would
be the standard y the y at the origin of
this form and the other position would
be a y which is partitioning into two
which is not just a partition into two
half half spaces
that would be the corresponding result
to borrel resort in the case of two
different partitions unfortunately we
can prove that this is not the optimal
partition
isn't it supposed to be like one
partition you want the first point of
the noise right so so that's i mean
there are various versions but all of
the proofs of moral result that we know
also also holds for two different
positions and also wait for five more
minutes i'm also going to address this
question in another way but just for now
what are the proofs that we know we do
we know for people also do partition is
actually a very easy proof that this is
not the optimal partition so why this is
not the optimal position
so this is very clear i mean this is the
this is the optimal partition i can just
draw at the optimal position here so
here's the optimal partition this is
going to be the three parts part one
part two and part three why is this the
optimal partition well we can prove it
using boral results we can prove that
this is not important but it's also
clear i'm telling you i'm running
election between candidates one two and
three and at the end of the election i'm
just going to ignore candidate number
three i'm going to throw them to the
garbage i'm going to say that they were
not born in the us and actually they
cannot be elected okay that's what i'm
going to do and i'm asking you what's
the most
the best way to elect the two countries
so you're going to say well i have to
assign probability one so to each of the
candidates so if there's a
great majority for one i'm going to say
that one means if there's a great
majority photo i'm going to say the two
wins and in the cases that i've
undetermined this i'm going to assign to
three because anyway i know that three
is not going to win and this is the most
stable partition and it's more stable
than this these two y's
right so you can prove it and you know
the proof shows that this is you know
whatever the extension of borrel resort
would be to two parts doesn't hold for
three parts in this setup but in india
as a professional complaint he said oh
but usually when we talk about you know
stateless we want the same partition
twice right and in many hardness of
approximation setup that's that's
sometimes what you want not always what
you want
so this is also not true if but we only
know it if the partitions are almost
balanced and always go to zero okay so
now i'm going to partition the space
once and i'm going to take two
correlated gaussians and i'm going to
ask the two correlated gaussians to land
in the same part of the space and the
claim is that among all partitions of r
into three parts such that the fourth
part has a measure of one surplus two
eta the second measure is the second and
the third part of measure one still
minus set at once and minus eta the
partition maximizing the probability
that you fall in the two parts is not
given by a standard y assuming that the
correlation law is sufficiently small
okay unfortunately some some smart and
not so small people conjectured that
plurality is stabilized so i'm you know
i'm involved in this group so you can
guess who are the smart and not smart
this still doesn't this still doesn't
contradict the conjecture that plurality
status because the smart people in the
plurality establish group made sure that
we only talk about balanced partition
where all the measures are exactly once
the advance of oneself so this doesn't
contradict the plurality of stables
conjecture but it continues something
very very close to that
what does it mean in election terms in
election terms it means for instance
suppose you're running an election and
you know the bias between the two
candidates one of them has a little bit
more chance than winning the two others
and you're asking what's the best way of
electing among the three candidates it's
not going to be a plurality election
it's going to be something else
and in the binary case majorities
majority is always if the biases are
moved in which direction majorities are
on the stability something much more
much more delicate is going on
okay
so let me tell you why this is true and
then then i think i'll run out of time
and finish the talk
so again this is true this is to only
when the quantity row is sufficiently
small
and the correlation is sufficiently
small and basically what you do is you
do an expansion when ro goes to zero so
when you do the expansion of when r goes
to zero as many of you know the the the
correlation between the f of x and f of
y well the first time is just coming
from the the zero zero level coefficient
which you know i'm writing it this way
this is vector notation right so this is
really the zero level fourier
coefficients and then they are going to
be the first order fourier coefficient
what are the first out of the
coefficient well the first order fourier
coefficients are just the center
the distance of the center of masses of
these partitions from the origin
square
okay so this is the standard y and we
turn out that if you shift the standard
wire a little bit
then the the
the center of mass is shifting away that
doesn't satisfy the problem so the
standard why we have the property that
all of these angles are 90 degrees i
don't know if i succeeded so this is 90
degrees this is 90 degree and this is 90
degree
and this is
this is 90 degree so all of these are 90
degrees and it turns out that if you
shift the standard wire a little bit and
you look at the center of masses it's
not 19 degrees and little more and if
it's not 90 degrees it turns out that
you can make a little bit of
modification of the sets that will
increase this quadratic quantity while
preserving the measure of the set so
it's not optimal
okay so what is the conclusion from that
the conclusion of that is that if
fluidity established is true
it's true
in very very special cases and all the
proofs that we are used to think about
proven inequalities like that do not
we you know really we don't know a proof
that is so specialized probably if it's
true there's some very interesting face
transitions that relates to wow and you
know you know some of the various
parameters coming to interplay in a much
more interesting way this project looks
even more ambitious than it looked ten
years ago five years ago and i started
singing about it okay so i stopped here
thank you
so is there some argument to say that at
least the boundaries are flat or the
sets are convex or
something like no i i don't know yeah i
don't i don't know any argument i think
you know maybe that's the way to start
thinking about it right more really in a
more
basic form
you know about what can you characterize
right and and one of the things that one
can try to do is to follow the
literature of the double bubble
ceiling proof which is a you know 10 or
15 papers and to try to see claim by
claim which claim you can prove right
because this is how they start you know
a lot of the work is just connectedness
and proving that the faces are you know
faces are nice and so on and so forth
but you know it's something that one can
try to do but i don't know any of the
statements uh currently
so so
the classical hyper contractivity gives
you
uh
various tale estimates on chaos
does do your
if you reverse the hyper contractivity
do you get some
information about the investment right
so it's something i thought about and i
i
i don't know i don't know any i don't
know any application all applications
that you should right so one thing it's
it's related to maybe some question that
was asked after comet talks one thing
that you have to take into account is
that in many of these stair estimates on
chaos we know that they become worse and
worse depending on the space that you're
looking at that if from gaza and you
move to some other space
right no but what i'm saying is that
whatever you do with reverse hyper
connectivity the result will not depend
on the space if you just use reverse
hyper connectivity on its own right so
the kind of estimates that you're
looking for
different than the usual estimates that
we know that that do depend on the space
and one candidate i was actually looking
after the talk was this bulgarian
statement about comparing the q norm of
this i mean so this is a kind of
statement that doesn't depend on the
space so statements like that which we
are usually not not
bogen sorry burgundy's estimate so so
this this this estimate this kind of
estimate we may try to prove this way
but i don't know any any proof that
actually goes along this line it's a
very natural question
and india
it's not measured like that it's not a
max of the meaning
right so maybe there is something going
on
if you change the definition not taking
the sum
you mean here for this problem right but
for this one i mean the question about
the stability is actually coming i mean
the application is very
you know the reason that people
conjecture that plurality is tableless
is that it's a very natural extension of
the fact that majority statement right
if you think about voting majority is
the best you know so you think what is
the extension of majority to other
voting setup it's plurality right so i
mean this this country i mean it's it's
it's true that one can think of
alternative questions but you know there
was a reason for the question being
asked the way it was outside so but it's
you know still one can explore other
direction but that was the reason the
question was asked this way
okay
thank you